we got we got a couple articles that are
a little bit old but we're going back
into the issue of men being you know
losers but it's not necessarily their
fault because we were talking about how
society has created this weird pressure
where women must and men must not write
and so we have this story I want to read
a little bit of it as a launching off
point this is called millennial men need
to man up the attack on traditional
notions of masky masculinity is creating
a generation of insecure incompetence
and I want to stop right there and say
brutal but it's not just the men it's
creating your incompetent men and women
yeah and I don't know if it's related to
relationships but let's just grab a
little bit of this because I want to
talk about that emotional intelligence
stuff yeah yeah they say modern feminism
spends a lot of time attacking toxic
masculinity and this attack which often
turns into an attack on traditional
gender roles is having serious
consequences it is leading to the
churning out of insecure non competitive
men who can't seem to manage basic life
skills it also means that trying to find
an interesting person to connect with
let alone a life partner is becoming
more and more of a challenge with
generation woke but it's not even just
men you know they're like it's it's more
like basic Millennials who are children
like this is where the title of the
stream Millennials are immature or
petulant children you end up with guys
who don't compete because they're told
not to they're told the sit still shut
up and then you end up with women who
are like I don't even think it the right
way I don't think you can describe it as
competing but everything is a slight
against them so you've got these overly
aggressive angry women in the workplace
and these timid ineffectual men who are
like whatever you say dear mm-hmm and so
so well yeah let's read more about toxic
masculinity and then we'll go back to
what real masculinity should should be
and more importantly this is gonna be
segwaying into emotional intelligence is
not being taught in schools so basically
you have now a lot of overly aggressive
like far left weird fake feminists angry
seething you know you've got these
Antipa types clubbing people over the
head and then you got dudes in their
basement and it is a dual problem and so
I'll mention the Suk's I did a video
about it before I think Jordan Peterson
one of the reasons he's so popular
specifically because of the inverse the
lack of responsibility and lack of
purpose yeah creates a void that people
were looking for something to give them
that message well he also talks about
men being more masculine and and being
the man in and you know I remember what
I was talking about or what what he said
the other day is about
we're losing the family aspect and like
how important family is and and the
American family is almost non-existent
anymore you know now it's a bunch of
single mothers with the dads ran off and
like you know now they're the 35 year
olds searching for the 22 year old the
35 year old woman is like Lord or dude
it's the woman left and then we're or
the woman left yeah you know it's like
but the family we're losing that you
know it's like everyone's doing their
own thing you get your own place you get
your own spot you you do your own thing
it's like well do you have your own
thing built up and it's like well what
happened to just like being a family and
working together towards something it's
like I think this what we're losing that
too I mean there's a lot of things that
caused that to break up yeah yeah modern
economics for instance mhm so I'll give
you an example of how you know I was
sort of dating somebody okay we both
worked all the time you know we never
saw each other relationship over yeah if
she or I had been you know I case stay
at home figure right then there would
have been a relationship but there's an
expectation that everyone has to have a
job and you know the craziest thing is I
saw there's a bunch of people on OkCupid
and I've seen these profiles they're
rare but they say things like society is
forcing me to do this like they don't
say it like that yeah but there have
been a few profiles I've talked some
women who say things like I would prefer
to be a stay-at-home housewife and
mother but I can't because I guess it's
not allowed anymore and those are rare
it's really rare but I wonder how many
women feel that way and can't say
anything about it because there's
expectations in society or how many men
feel that way exactly if they're even
allowed to feel that way like what if a
guy feels that way everyone's gonna be
like whoa you want to be a stay-at-home
dad and not work like hmm that goes
against everything that we're taught so
this is this is a really good problem
with what they call feminism
you never hear or you rarely hear and go
that we need rights for fathers it's
almost always about the woman getting
more rights and it's a paternity leave
not paternity leave know it to be fair
there is a conversation never happen all
you know a parental leave well good but
but that is true to a certain degree
mm-hmm what I mean is though when you
end up looking at like men's rights
activist arguments they talk about
divorce courts favoring women okay and
they get insulted and berated for that
it may never made any sense to me I'm
like if a dude says hey it's not fair
that you know divorce court will give
custody to children to them and apes
under the time I'm like that's that's
correct that is unfair it shouldn't be
based on your gender that's you know
that's discrimination right and then
what do they do they say Mr raise is
like a huge negative if you are active
like as a as a men's rights activist
whatever reason and go you're outside
the mainstream you're gonna be insulted
yeah you know slam down and so what ends
up happening is we have this imbalance
where and I think this plays into
monuments failures demands that women be
given jobs they do big initiatives to
get more women involved in more industry
industry that women industries that
women don't choose and then as men fail
and drop out of school and now they're
the minority in colleges and now they're
you know they're they're well they're
actually recovering in the workplace is
gonna be a big thing when I talk about
but when I when they when when men are
failing it's just completely ignored
meanwhile they're talking about how we
need more female CEOs where's the
inverse where's the we need more females
cleaning sewers and gutters right it's
always about a cushy air conditioning
job it's never about real equality yeah
there are reasons why men are more
likely to work on an on an oil platform
than a woman you know it is dangerous
arduous cold and uncomfortable or the
fire fire you know thing you were
talking about the other day it's just
like wouldn't you rather have the big
you know burly guy that was here it's
practical and it's cuz he's 64 and can
lift you easily and carry you out of the
fire yeah or I mean you know generally
speaking the man is gonna have a stature
that's gonna be able to carry you you
know you know one of the craziest things
I ever read was a woman writing about
how it working in Antarctica is sexist
what because men can pee outside
I'm not kidding that's it yeah and so
she said they need to install outhouses
appear in rent and different areas where
they're doing research because not fun
it's not fair men can just you know
unzip and release well when they're not
peeing at the girl are they they're
going around to a probably private spot
and peeing but it's not sexist to not
build an outhouse it's like there's no
outhouse dude you know that doesn't make
good so she wants the men to go pee in
an outhouse no no no we'd have to or she
was a decided go to the bathroom she
can't she has to go back to the station
okay so her argument was it's it's
sexist because when her and the men go
to do research and they have to go to
the bathroom the guy can just pee
wherever he wants well actually I know
for a fact that women there's this
device they told me outside so she ended
up doing that yeah and wrote about her
experience in trying to learn how to use
the lady funnel fellini phone on yeah
and so it's like problem solved like but
the oh no it's sexist but that's that is
sexist because they have units that they
can use it was it she wasn't targeting
my visual amendment say on here so but
she wasn't targeting the individual men
she was talking about patriarchy and she
was like the system is built for men
because if women built it there would be
outhouses and my argument is no where
where are they doing studies like
wouldn't they be changing their their
spot where they're studying different
environments different body different
like got to bring that port-a-potty and
set up an outhouse everywhere they go
that's a thing you're on the frontier
yeah exactly so you're out in the you
know no-man's land it's well I mean I
guess what your countries are claiming
you know Antarctica in various portions
yeah yeah but still it's like dude if
you want to go trekking about in the
wilderness
you can't blame patriarchy for the fact
that dude's got Wang's like a name yeah
but that's let's write their names but
so take that insane mentality and now
apply it to how they're attacking men
for toxic masculinity
yeah and men are retreating because I
see society as a whole
how you can't argue it you can't there's
nothing a man can say because it's just
more toxic smash keulen it exactly what
it is line it oh oh you're gonna say
anything right now more toxic masculine
boom you're you're even worse now
because you're even trying to defend
because I'm right they thought they
called on period they called the
pendulum swing okay that you know I was
talking to these activists and they say
for the longest time men were in control
and it's outward turn now see that's
that's that doesn't make sense
that's not pheasant that's not feminism
I mean it is well it's the new feminism
right the New Age feminism so here's the
funny thing though I guarantee you
already mm-hmm there's probably a bunch
of feminists who like hate watch my
content yeah and they're like writing
all these things down like Tim's and
Angele blah blah blah blah blah I never
said men don't have privileges and men
don't have special access and things
that make them you know better suited
for certain things right or that men are
benefiting in many ways I'm specifically
talking about how if you really believe
in equality mm-hmm then you have to take
the good with the bad
right and there was really really funny
I don't know if you saw this when the
Senate was proposing bringing women into
the combat draft and then all of a
sudden Twitter lit up and I swear I
thought it was a parody like they were
feminists saying I never meant this no
way stop take it back I take it back
really oh you don't want to go to the
Middle East and die leave that to the
men huh combat many combat deaths are
like what 98% male really yeah nobody's
talking about closing that gap that
would be insane or how about suicides
five times more men you know kind of
committing suicide don't talk about
closing that gap how about homelessness
no one's talking about closing that gap
right so you if you want to talk about
patriarchy I think the problem is they
don't understand that there's like a
there's a bell curve
to talent and idiocy
there are more male geniuses and more
male morons okay and more women in the
middle so I think that makes sense then
because if you have a hundred men at a
hundred women the average women are
gonna see a lot more really dumb dudes
getting in their way
mm-hmm but then they're gonna get mad at
the top-tier men because there's too
many but that's just how humans have
have split up right right so now we're
seeing this weird cutoff the tall grass
and it results in men not going to
college they're the minority now and it
resulted in this really terrifying
phenomenon let me pull this article get
to the crock
of this segment even though we're
already really really far in millennial
men leave perplexing whole in hot u.s.
job market the economy has been booming
and this article from November 2nd 2018
was freaky men from ages 25 to 34 are
less likely to work than before half a
million young men are missing and it
isn't clear why now I'm gonna tell you
why people are gonna vote for Donald
Trump in 2020 and I hate to bring up
politics because we're talking cultural
issues but take a look at this article
now men aged 25 to 34 now working at the
highest rate since the recession so
that's in 11 years and that was only
about six months later oh wow six months
later there was a major recovery where
the men were missing and all of a sudden
their jobs started coming in they
started working again so I'll tell you
what whatever whatever is happening
right now in culture I can tell you
there's a lot of dudes who are really
really happy about so you're saying
that's Trump that did that well
I'm being a bit hyperbolic that's why no
I'm definitely being a bit hyperbolic in
like truck came and pulled all these
guys out of the gutter yeah yeah no but
I'm saying the economy is doing really
really well look at this yeah yeah pull
it up so that's it yeah young men are
working so I think I thought well
interestingly there could still be men
missing from this this number true
because they're not they're not
necessarily one-for-one correlations
right right but I think it doesn't
matter if Trump made it happen or if he
contributed to it at all it happened
matters that it happened under his watch
and there's a bunch of young guys so so
I want to get away from talking about
Trump I really do not I do too you know
I like to talk about this article looks
like well well gents go talk about
Jordan Peterson all right and we'll
segue into this emotional charger he's
telling people be responsible mm-hmm
he's become wildly popular I mean look
you know Michael he hated to the same
time yeah by these these weirdos yeah
you know it you know the crazy you don't
one of the craziest things is and and
just coming from somebody who has never
been conservative Tucker Carlson has the
number one news show in the country
basically okay and the media acts like
he's a fringe character it's like dude
he is that his show's bigger than yours
yeah by like the
million people yeah daily wire is the
biggest news outlet on on Facebook or
one of the most shared and most engaged
with yeah and you're acting like what
they're saying is fringe dude it's like
they live in this weird world and
they're freaking out what we're seeing
now with the intellectual dark web with
Peterson and and people like him yeah is
a recovery in the people on at least
whatever this space is not right-wing
but it was people who didn't have
emotional intelligence and now that that
whatever that is because I don't wanna
say the left but kind of yeah they
certainly do not have emotional
intelligence and they're resisting and
shrieking well you know they don't and
it also feels like people are kind of
both women and men are kind of becoming
aware of this like craziness that is
going on that people are like this is
not actual reality this is this is wrong
yeah let's get back to regular life
almost you know like look what is
reality let's go there because this is
so so interesting interestingly enough
this article comes from Lifehacker which
is I think part of the is this part of
okay I don't know who owns lifehacker
anymore but I'm pretty sure it used to
be one of these weird lefty outlets so
they say what is emotional intelligence
measuring emotional intelligence is
relatively new in the field of
psychology only first being explored in
the mid 1980s several models are
currently being developed but for our
purpose we'll examine what's known as
the mixed model developed by Daniel
Goleman he first came across the term
emotional intelligence in 1990 when he
was a science reporter for the New York
Times and by chance came across an
article in a small academic journal by
two psychologists John Mayer and Peter
Peter Salovey which offered the first
content of emotional intelligence 15
years later goldman wrote an article for
the same newspaper outlining the five
key areas of the mixed mode of emotional
intelligence see I love this so much
like this needs to be taught in schools
like this you know I I learned this
later on in life you know like into my
30s I started like really questioning
myself questioning my motives
questioning what I'm doing you know
understanding myself really and and I
wish I'd learned that 20 years prior you
know I went that's what this is all
about let's read these points
it's great self-awareness knowing your
own feelings management being able to
keep your emotions in check
motivation obviously you know however
you motivate yourself said it
satisfaction and curiosity joy of being
productive empathy they say well the
three previous categories of virtual
person's internal emotions this one
deals with the emotions of others this
is huge empathy is the skill and
practice of reading the emotions of
others and responding appropriately
mmm-hmm
social skills this category involves the
application of empathy as well as
negotiating the needs of others with
your own it can include finding common
ground with others managing others in a
work environment and being persuasive
you know and I'm gonna tell you straight
up yeah this is huge the authoritarians
in today's politics lack all of these
agreed the libertarians have all of
these so I think absolutely hmm empathy
I believe people with extreme empathy
for others become super libertarian okay
because you don't want other people to
feel the way like feel bad the way you
you understand you understand where
they're at and you go I don't want you
to feel like that how can we fix it yeah
exactly exactly I wouldn't want someone
so so you know I wouldn't want someone
to come and tell me that my
constitutional rights are being
curtailed so I'm not gonna go and say
the same thing to you because I don't
want you to feel that way too right but
self-awareness look man there's a bunch
of crazy lunatics wearing all black
running around bashing skulls they have
no idea what they look like they're
completely not self-aware right they
can't keep their emotions in check you
see this video where there's a bunch of
young college conservatives they're
doing like flyering and a guy walks up
and starts screaming at the top of his
lungs these people have never been
taught anything in philosophy or like
mental management yeah
so they're not motivated they have no
purpose they have no self-awareness they
have no empathy they don't care how you
feel or what you think and I absolutely
have no social skills and the internet
just made that exponentially worse no
these people probably worse on the
internet know that though the people
that are self-aware and all that that
have emotional intelligence are probably
not in there as much they don't need
that they don't need to get their kicks
from online
I don't think I don't think I don't
think Internet plays as big a role
actually I think so I think if you're
online you're probably being exposed to
more information okay and I think it may
be why online is dominated by the right
I'm doing air quotes because a lot of
these people they call right wing are
not well I was saying you you mentioned
like these people wearing all-black
that aren't aware are yeah there's
nothing they were to get group up they
were to fun into the the frenzy that and
then they go off to not burn buildings
because they're not so is this is
interesting I think if you have some
self-awareness and empathy mmm-hmm
you're probably sitting back questioning
why you're not succeeding yeah you then
stumble across a book called twelve
rules for life right you see this guy
who's like pick up you know find the
heaviest thing you can and carry it yeah
and you're aware and I'm clean your room
and clean your room bucko but you but
you listen and Peterson's not perfect by
no sir to the imagination
right right but that resonates with
people who are aware yeah now what if
you're not aware what if you're not
motivate one to know they want to
further themselves right if you have no
self-awareness no empathy or motivation
or social skills you're sitting there
and then someone comes along and says Oh
Peterson yeah he's far right and they go
you got it I'll just say whatever you
told me to say right and they go March
off like zombie sheave just believe
whatever they're told so it was
interesting that you brought this
article up because I feel like it's a
really good example of a lot of the
problems in our political landscape
I've been trying every one's been trying
to figure out is it left versus right
some have said authoritarian versus
libertarian nationalists versus
globalist none of these things really
make sense but I think we can see here
it's the emotionally intelligent versus
the non emotionally the people with some
semblance of self-awareness on what they
are and what they think and what they
feel and what others feel also and the
funny thing is there's always been
mind-blowing to me that they claim the
exact same thing but that's just not
true right it's not because when you
look at well because it's me I'm right
though I'm I'm right but I can tell you
why not if you're not part of this you
know those people are all think they're
right all the time and so do we though
true true but guess what hmm so does
Dave Chappelle Dave Chappelle thinks we
are right in terms of like we
offensive jokes yeah we can be humorous
and all these comedians and in
mainstream pop culture is being
dominated by this fringe wacko nonsense
that is not popular okay because regular
people reject this weirdo nonsense now
they claim we're the ones with real
empathy that's why we want to ban speech
and it's like no you're not because if
you understand what that meant you would
know that there are a lot of people who
will be hurt by this mm-hmm you don't
care because you can't think about what
they feel right yeah well this needs to
be taught in schools this needs to be a
school subject and it's not you know
nutrition learning what the human body
needs to eat and and to survive and like
mental awareness telus ism Mamet ism
yeah these things need to be in taxes
yeah yeah finance finances like those
that should be math class like we don't
need to learn calculus we need to learn
taxes we need to learn about saving
money and and being able to thrive in
the world that we have currently you
know like this I know I'm kind of like
getting into education a little bit but
the American education we definitely
need thanks for checking out this
segment from the Tim cast IRL podcast we
do the show every Monday through Friday
at 8 p.m. sometimes an hour or two and
we do have a full live recorded version
of the show that includes a lot of
comments and smaller segments you
probably don't see if you want to check
that out you can watch live at 8:00 p.m.
Monday through Friday or become a member
of this channel and for five bucks a
month you get full access to all of the
recorded podcasts every day after the
show we make them available in the
community section of this YouTube
channel so don't forget to subscribe and
stick around for more segments and more
shows Monday through Friday at 8 p.m.
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next show
you